when someone rules an empire they
normally take the title emperor or
empress yet despite having a pretty
chunky empire the british monarchs were
never styled as the british emperor or
empress
which raises the question why why wasn't
the british empire ruled over by a
british emperor
now it's important to note that most
emperors didn't simply convert their
title from that of a king
many had adopted it on top of their
previous titles and others did so after
major change in government
furthermore it often claims to be the
continuation of a previous imperial
title
britain never had any of this and so
there was no pretext to change the royal
title when their role in the type of
government that they led was the same as
always
in fact when there was a major change by
the monarch that of henry viii declaring
england's separation from the catholic
church it was written into law that
england was effectively from that point
onwards an empire and that henry and all
of his successors would carry the rights
and status of emperors but would simply
use the title of king instead
another reason was somewhat more
particular to britain you see after the
17th century the british developed an
extreme allergic reaction to absolute
monarchy in a title like empress screams
i'm a king of kings and thus in charge
and won't be sharing much power with
anyone which to parliament was a no-no
another reason was that britain itself
wasn't seen as being some multi-ethnic
empire in the same way as
austria-hungary was but in the eyes of
its rulers britain was a nation of
nations who were all equal
theoretically at least in practice not
so much this is one of the reasons why
george iii when offered the title of
british emperor in 1801 refused it
and another was because he was an
elector of the holy roman empire at this
point and so an emperor electing another
emperor whom he would hold some
allegiance to was just a bit silly
this wasn't the last time that the topic
of imperial titles would come up
you see as of the 1870s there were a lot
of emperors in europe
and the title of emperor outranks that
of king or queen which upset britain's
queen victoria who didn't want to be
seen as everyone's inferior
at this point a monarch adopting an
imperial title with respect to britain
was unacceptable and so the sitting
prime minister benjamin israeli offered
to give a different imperial title that
of empress of india
the reason why this was okay was that
one india was the crown jewel of the
empire and the one which britain was
most proud of
two it was made up of many smaller
kingdoms and principalities and so the
title could maintain the implication
that it meant king of kings and
three india and its people weren't seen
as being equal to those of britain and
so absolute rule over them was just fine
but why not extend it to the rest of the
empire well much like britain places
like canada and australia had the same
anti-authoritarian position
and as for the rest of the empire well
it wasn't seen as being prestigious
enough to warrant the title of emperor
there was still opposition to the title
from many liberal politicians but it was
brought into force in 1876
and victoria's successors would all
thereafter be empress of india until its
independence in 1947
which is why britain and the british
empire didn't have an emperor but only
one part of it india did and for just
over 70 years
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker marvin
cassow moe
rob waterhouse aaron the white james
castaneda jordan longley
gustav swan jerry landon marcus asner
maggie paxkowski rasheed ali
miss iset david silverman coppertone
winston cayward matthew shipley
spinning three plates anthony beckett
spencer lightfoot lexi schwinn robert
wedzil skye chappelle
and charles the first